[Musique]
bonsoir
un constat simple et je lave ou
effectivement vous êtes nombreux trop
nombreux
j'avais une idée pour illustrer le début
de mon intervention
une idée simple tous vous emmener dehors
et vous faire déambuler dans les rues de
lille mais on va très vite fait
comprendre
non pas que c'était impossible et vous
comprendrez tout à l'heure que le terme
impossible n'a pas été utilisé
intelligemment mais qui serait difficile
pour moi de faire tenir tout ça dans 18
minutes
alors pourquoi je voulais vous emmener
ce soir dans l'île tout simplement pour
vous confronter à une situation que tout
le monde a déjà rencontré celle de
croiser un sans domicile fixe
assis par terre en train de faire la
manche pourquoi tout simplement pour
étudier même si au fond de moi je
connais déjà les réponses vos réactions
face à tête face à cette situation
qu'elle aurait été vos réactions pour
80% d'entre vous vous auriez soit
détourné le regard soit modifié votre
chemin pour éviter cette personne pour
19 99 % d'entre vous vous auriez
sûrement donner une pièce mais ce qui
m'intéresse ce sont les 0 01 % de
personnes restantes qui aurait fait ces
personnes des personnes comme vous comme
moi des personnes normales qui par une
action banale peuvent créer écrire
raconte est modifié de belles histoires
pour illustrer ces 0 0 1%
je vais prendre un exemple une vidéo que
l'ensemble d'entre vous je pense via les
réseaux sociaux ont déjà vu c'est
l'histoire de ce jeune américain
une vingtaine d'années ils déambulent
dans la rue et lui aussi tombe sur un
sdf
sa réaction très simple
allez acheter une pizza s'asseoir à côté
de lui la partager entamer le dialogue
la viralité de l'information aujourd'hui
vont faire et nous allons la prendre
plus tard que ce sdf finira par sortir
de la rue et reprendre une vie normale
ma première question qui est le grand
gagnant celui qui donne sans ne rien
attendre en retour
ou celui qui reçoit sans avoir rien
demandé
une autre vidéo une autre histoire qui
me touche un peu plus c'est celle d'un
gamin un gamin de 12 ans tétraplégique
enfermé dans son corps cet enfant n'a
qu'un rêve celui de participer à une
course extrême cette course c'est un
triathlon un triathlon qu'on nomme iron
man pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
c'est très simple principe du moins sur
le papier
4 km de natation enchaîné avec 180 km de
vélo pour finir par un petit marathon de
42 km en course à pied
cet enfant n'a pas le choix s'il veut y
participer
il doit motiver son père il en parle à
son père et à force de persuasion va
réussir à convaincre son père de
l'emmener sur cette course son père va
s'entraîner avec lui et tout au long de
cet entraînement
ils vont rencontrer à chaque fois les
mêmes réactions c'est impossible
vous ne pourrez pas le faire et eux
puisque c'est impossible
alors faisons le pourquoi cette vidéo de
touche
peut-être parce que je fais du triathlon
que j'ai découvert qui me permet de
toujours repousser mes limites d'aller
plus loin de réfléchir dans l'effort 2
comme dans tout le sport d'avoir de
belles valoir du dépassement de soi plus
personnel une chose que j'apprécie dans
le triathlon
c'est pourquoi être mauvais dans un
sport quand on peut l'être dans trois
faut savoir l'avouer après le handicap
peut-être que le handicap dans cette
vidéo me touche eh bien non j'ai 42 ans
je ne suis ni moi même ni ma famille me
non cercles proches touchés par le
handicap le handicap
je vais le découvrir je les biens
découvert avant comme l'y pourcentage
que vous expliquez 80% du temps plus le
handicap est lourd plus mon regard va
fuir cet handicap dans 19 points 99 %
des cas
oui j'ai déjà aidé des gens a décroché
un paquet de pâtes un petit peu au dans
un commerce à aider un malvoyant à
traverser il restait c'est 0 0 1% alors
le handicap
je ne vais pas le découvrir je vais le
prendre en pleine face
il y a un petit peu plus de deux ans
alors président d'un club service nous
avons dans l'adn de ce club
une idée une envie d'aider une action
locale une action caritative
je viens donc à rencontrer un médecin un
médecin chef de service dans un hôpital
pas très loin d'ici sur berck là où je
réside ce médecin soigne réparé et remet
sur le chemin de la vie des amputés et
comme je vous disais le handicap
je vais le prendre en pleine face entre
deux portes entre la porte d'entrée de
cet hôpital et la porte du bureau de ce
médecin est là c'est peut-être stupide
mais je me rends compte que le handicap
touche tout le monde et surtout
l'amputation jeunes ados adultes vieux
hommes femmes et surtout quand une
fraction de seconde
vous pouvez perdre un deux trois ou
quatre membres je viens donc la
rencontre et ce médecin
ce médecin un projet un projet simple
réaliser le rêve d'une petite fille
cette petite fille âgée de 8 ans alors à
l'âge de 18 mois a subi une méningite
foudroyante
le résultat amputation des deux jambes
amputation de la main et son visage en
garde les stigmates
cette petite fille a un rêve simple
courir dans ma tête elle n'a pas de
jambes elle veut courir on parle
forcément de financer un fauteuil de
roullens de course
mais très vite ce médecin m'explique que
des personnes sans jambes peuvent qui
leur manque une jambe courir courir
grâce à nos éléments simples cet élément
s'appelle une lame de course en carbone
cette lame la voix 6 grâce à un principe
simple de restitution d'énergie la
personne peut refaire du sport ou tout
simplement reprendre une activité
sportive comme tout le monde
cette lame à trois gros soucis au delà
d'apporter le bonheur de pouvoir faire
du sport je vous évoque les deux
premiers soucis là est un petit peu plus
tard le troisième
le premier c'est non pris en charge pas
assez d'aidé sociale parce que c'est
classé comme outil de confort on peut
faire un raccourci rapide
le sport c'est du confort deuxième
soucis inhérents totalement au premier
son coût de 1500 euros n'étant pas très
fort en maths
j'arrive quand même à comprendre que ces
cinq mille euros que je vais devoir
trouver pour financer le rêve de cette
petite fille instantanément je lui dis
oui oui nous allons avec mes membres de
mon club
s'engager à financer ses lames 5000
euros nous les trouverons assez
rapidement et puis quelques temps après
ce médecin m'invite à découvrir la
petite fille qui prend possession de ces
dames
et comme dans 80% des statistiques
je vois cette petite fille arrivée
effectivement sans jambes dans un
fauteuil roulant poussé par sa maman est
instinctive n'en mon regard s'échappe
mais très vite je redécouvre cette
petite fille chaussée sur ses lames
sellam tout d'un coup et fasse le
handicap et cette petite fille se met à
courir en un instant cette petite fille
me montre me démontre et surtout me
prouve qu'il est possible de courir sans
jambles en quelque sorte cette petite
fille de 8 ans a fait de moi un colosse
aux pieds d'argile
le troisième problème simple sellam
nécessite d'être changées tous les 18
mois en fonction du poids et de
l'évolution de la taille de l'enfant ce
qui signifie que pour cette petite fille
ce n'est plus deux mais cette paire de
l'âme que nous allons devoir financer
entre 7 et 8 pers soit un budget de 40
mille euros pour qu'un enfant puisse
faire du sport jusqu'à son âge adulte
après avoir vu cette petite fille courir
impossible de dire non et je dis oui oui
à titre personnel je trouverais certains
agents pardon je trouverais certains cet
argent je motiverait mais famille mes
amis je suis chef d'entreprise
j'irai le voir mes clients mes
fournisseurs ménouret la réaliseront
leur rêve de petite fille et puis et
puis nous discutons avec ses médecins
un lien s'installe une osmose une
symbiose et on se dit c'est l'hameçon du
carbone c'est quasi incassable quasi
immuable qu'elles ont nous faire une
fois que la petite aura grandi nous
allons financer notre père et celle ci
nous les laissons sur une étagère et là
on se dit et si on les prêtait un autre
enfant d'une taille inférieure à qui
elle vient de là il n'est donc l'idée de
prêter les lames
une fois que la petite on aura fait
usage l'idée se répand une maman de
calais nous appelle puis de dunkerque et
on ça on ça qu on s'attache à ce que ces
enfants eux aussi puissent bénéficier de
ces lames et on a un rêve on se dit est
bas essayons bbc enfants du nord pas de
calais c'est notre région et dont les et
un jour une maman de pavant une maman
damien nous appelle la même histoire les
mêmes problèmes le même rêve un gosse
qui voit nos champions paralympiques sur
internet courir il veut faire la même
chose
problème amiens dans le nord pas de
calais c'est impossible
eh bien puisque c'est possible puisque
c'est impossible nous allons faire et on
se dit ouvrons donc cette idée à tout le
grand nord de paris
et puis ce qui devait arriver arriva un
jour la même histoire le même rêve d'un
gosse le un gros problème
bordeaux bordeaux dans le grand nord de
paris
c'est totalement impossible que faisons
nous nous appelons la maman pour lui
dire qu'en plus que son enfant subit un
deuxième handicap d'être né trop loin et
puis non on se dit c'est impossible
c'est totalement impossible
bordeaux dans grand nord de paris ce
n'est pas réalisable
vous le savez je suis jean marc l'ongle
et avec le docteur frédéric charlaté
nous avons il ya un petit peu moins de
deux ans créé et l'âme de joie larmes de
joie c'est une banque de prêt de l'âme
de carbone à destination de tous les
enfants de france il n'y a aucun frais
pour les familles c'est totalement
gratuit sans caution et sans condition
de ressources
l'âme de joie c'est une action sang pour
sang bénévoles
financé à 100% par des dons privés
d'entreprises de particuliers d'actions
sportives et culturelles et de quelques
fondations qui comme nous pensent que le
sport peut être ouvert à tous l'âme de
joie ses augustes c et anne c'est erwan
c'est alex tendre c'est anna et ses
vingt-cinq autres enfants qui en moins
de deux ans sont rentrés dans le
programme dame de joie larmes de joie
c'est aussi un engagement celui de
financer les lames aux enfants quand qui
tu parles quand ils quitteront le
programme plein de joie pour qu'il
puisse entrer dans l'âge adulte sans
rompre leurs liens qu'ils ont avec le
sport l'âme de joie c'est donc
aujourd'hui trois enfants qui ont déjà
quitté le programme mais dame de joie
c'est aussi des belles histoires
des histoires d'amitié des histoires de
sport de foot de tennis de danse de
capoeira mais tout simplement des
histoires de jeux de mômes larmes de
joie c'est aussi un rêve celui d'équipé
tous les enfants amputés de france l'âme
de joie c'est un combat celui de faire
du sport autre chose qu'un confort et de
faire prendre en charge ces lames
finalement l'âme de joie c'est quoi ces
des enfants qui vous prouve que
l'impossible est possible et c'est leur
offrir comme à leurs camarades
la possibilité d'aller à l'école avec un
sac de sport mais l'âme de joie c'est
aussi désormais vous ce soir vous êtes
nos ambassadeurs par l'est et par les
ans pour que plus aucun enfant
aujourd'hui ne reste sur un banc d'une
école à regarder ses copains jouer dans
une cour où faire du sport et puis la
vie c'est quoi on dit que des rancunes
rencontre peut changer votre vie - ce
sont deux rencontres
la première celle de cette petite fille
de 7
si ça pouvait marcher
voilà celle de cette petite fille inaya
à 8 ans qui est la première bénéficiaire
qui en juillet 2016 a reçu sa paire de
l'âme et qui quelques mois après a aussi
pu réaliser un autre rêve celui
d'intégrer un club d'athlétisme avec des
enfants valides et puis dame de joie
c'est surtout une personne un médecin un
médecin qui a décidé d'aller un peu plus
loin que son rôle de médecin
un homme un homme aux grandes valeurs
qui m'a fait découvrir l'altruisme et la
philanthropie un homme et ça j'en suis
très fier qui est devenu un métier
devenu un meilleur ami je vous demande
de l'accueillir pour qu'il finisse avec
moi cette intervention
c'est le docteur frédéric charlaté
[Musique]
et puis et puis vous l'attendez vous
l'attendez la réponse cette réponse qui
est le grand gagnant celui qui donne ou
celui qui reçoit
pour ma part j'ai la réponse je suis
espère bien que ses 0,01 pour cent ce
soir je vous les ai transmis et à vous
maintenant de faire en sorte de trouver
la réponse
et je terminerai juste par une chose je
vous invite pas à changer le monde
je vous incite juste un volet plus beaux
rêves merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]